all right how's it going bros my name is
beard back welcome back to octal and
continued start over continuum dude dip
I'm freaking after that for those who
aren't who aren't familiar with Octodad
you're well here you go hey pretty much
your [ __ ] octopus and that's pretty
much it you're damn fine octopus I mean
just look at me alright to do in the
master bedroom we're actually gonna go
away when yesterday I'm probably not
yesterday actually I want to pick up
it's fine
China that looks super expensive no not
the back alright alright let's pick it
up there we go
oh yeah let's forget okay let's just go
with this it's my the Frogner not oh
sweet I did it I think I'm going the
right way
oh yes yes alright whatever we've seen
this we have to save her from the
spiders or something I don't I don't
even know anymore
it looks like he's breakdancing yeah
yeah you got probably a river dancing
octa that would be really pretty damn
sweet River dancing there's a monster
let's just [ __ ] him up [ __ ] get out of
my house
that's we will meet again octopus yeah
I'm [ __ ] after that
nah okay I'll do the comment here talk
there Dan hey we get these acrobatic
skills look at this I'm freaking act mad
Jesus Christ my baby's ugly
I wish here we go how you doing girl hey
girl
how you doing how you doing hi dream
girl come on out yawning I'm stack after
that it's stuck I could climb I know up
there really
oh she's like that that's fine I mean
okay let's kill the spiders let's kill
those fight where's the spiders
I'm gonna get you oh there's a spider
come on your spider i'ma fight you off
[ __ ] I got tentacles and [ __ ] go go
after that part yes no yes no okay I'll
see you I see you I see you go kill it
kill this Paola did I get it
alright I think we're good my job is
done
now the spider all right my spider come
here come on [ __ ] well there's so many
all right fine
let's just fight them off like an hour
after dad - all right Riverdance
I go left I go right after spiders all
night how the [ __ ] they killed them out
of Crick an army of spiders what do you
want from me okay then it of course I
did
she's still scared find a story book to
read and she'll calm down all right
let's find how about this what does it
say that I don't want to read some bad
new K talk to that Jesus cried all its
octo freaking dad hole it's still tall
whatever is good enough ah no yes
alright let's go let's read this
freaking story toy doctor alright girl
girl it's time we read I'm coming in to
hide worked this is how I read stories
in this position oh hey girl hey girl
how you doing how you doing you like
octopuses you like you like - you're
like you're like when you do this you
like my alright let's just get out of
here before I get a replacement gone
from the toy chest to replace octave all
the blue dolphin should work
all right oh it's over here it's over
here I'm just gonna go let go with the
bug doctor dad Jesus Christ I know you
liked a bit better I'm just gonna rip a
little over Riverdance my way out of
here okay it's time to open the locket
yep yep and that Rick no yeah neither
Blue Dolphin where's the Blue Dolphin as
it is now
get out of my face stupid thing is this
yeah it's the Blue Dolphin help it's the
blood I found you mr. Blue Dolphin
okay this is trying now that you're not
a Blue Dolphin
are you come on there yes just a fine
you're so fine come on no no no you
don't need one after that all right come
on come on girl come on you're so sweet
yes yes I got the octo doll I mean the
blue finger leading Lee okay all right
let's do some [ __ ] serious [ __ ] going
on here doctor dad it's on fire
hey girl you want this I heard you don't
oh you wanted my bad
I'll show you my bad why don't you tell
me
from that but how do I replace that what
do you want from me
take it girl take it all right I need
replace Oh No yeah they go oh I need to
replace it quick
no knock they got no he made me into
sushi now Wow cheap - that's all I'm
worth do it all you three bucks all
right me I was difficult to help dr. dad
I mean after that you need to shape up
shape up anyway let's the sky's Hasbro
again yeah come on get out of my house
get out of my house get out of my house
what the [ __ ] is that
yeah alright yeah it's break dancing
that's what I call breakdown yeah I'm a
breakdown I'm the king I'm dance floor
right here alright enough [ __ ] hurrah
that was it for buck to that today hope
you guys enjoyed like a favor did
subscribe if you did and I'll see you
tomorrow
eyebrows I decided to do another mission
cuz it was kind of short I didn't know I
have someone recording for seven minutes
let's go deliver home octave dadelus
let's just let's just go I just yes he's
a douchebag oh my dad my son is a
douchebag
that's my dinner suit that's an ugly
suit ever you know spiders secret game
fish haha beautiful oh it's on now
hooker dad oh man I can't wait for
sports Johnson and the football no John
you don't manage with after that not
even my son now freakin kill ya alright
girl I mean boy oh come on boy I'll kill
ya I [ __ ] kill ya I'll kill ya
I'll kill you I'll tell you here let me
slap ya let me slap you let me let me
slap you
kid kid I'm gonna slap you I'm gonna
freaking out to push slap you
this could be my penis you know I'm big
penis laughing you whatever did you see
that is that come here son
and lick my balls actually no that's
inappropriate actually all right then
this spoiled brat look at this room it's
like five yeah there's an old fireplace
alright fine I'll show you my moves oh
yeah I call this one the octopus
backflip shot cut almost all right let's
try that again
talk to that doctor dad talk to dad
go alright one to go yeah now can I pick
up the football who's gonna take a cup
for she's slow
alright course it wears oh there's ball
alright I got it
Hey ha ha octo-octo-octopus for me do it
and now shoot it's alright I got it this
time I got it this time breasts alright
alright I got it now I got enough
alright shoot Octodad focus focus please
for the love of your penis I don't even
know where often that was super good
let's do that again
now after dad what are you doing Go Go
Go yes
no it was so close so close alright do
it again
ah so close again put it down there girl
boy that all right this one is some
glory
[Music]
all right I got I got it now what ah
Jesus penis so annoying I hate my son
hey Chan what what what super awesome
alright one more let's do this son
you're going down it's just you and me
buddy go it's just you and me buddy go
yeah how are you here
well you see about that son hi we see
about I like my boss make my boss do it
do it big mouth to catch balls do it do
it son do it son son okay fine you like
it front do it do it do it do it alright
escape the [ __ ] um no I that it's stuck
after that is merging with the goal
what's going on
I must have sex spazzing out after dad
is passing out sexual passing yes oh yes
now yes it's working
come on I thought you're almost out now
need to flee from crime now
now my leg my [ __ ] I had hurt so much
now oh my leg it's stuck out just add
the pain the pain it's still alright
fine all right I'm gonna face it
tomorrow I know I hope you brought in
the yard
I'll see you
[Music]